[Music]
with so much of the Russian military at
War this was a scaled down Victory Day
Parade
at least 20 000 Russian soldiers
mercenaries and volunteers have been
killed since Vladimir Putin ordered the
invasion of Ukraine 15 months ago
that figure is from independent
monitoring groups counting each reported
death the real figure may be much higher
President Vladimir Putin says Russians
are in a sacred fight against the West
which wants to carve up their territory
the Western globalist the lead still
preach about their exceptionalism they
are pitting people against each other in
dividing Society provoking bloody
conflicts and coups sowing hatred
risophobia aggressive nationalism
destroying the traditional family values
that make people people
Putin casts the invasion of Ukraine as a
defensive move saying the expansion of
NATO to its borders is a security threat
the Kiev and its allies Moscow is waging
an unprovoked war of aggression to seize
unbounded Ambitions arrogance and
permissiveness inevitably lead to
tragedy this is precisely the reason for
the catastrophe that the Ukrainian
people are currently experiencing they
have become hostages of coup d'etat and
the criminal regime of the western
Masters who took hold in its place a
bargaining chip in the execution of
their crew self-serving plans
[Music]
Tuesday's parade in Moscow are no
traditional flyover of military jets in
other cities parades were canceled or
reduced in size due to security concerns
and a shortage of troops and arms at the
front lines
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera